here's a practical trick to convert  celsius and fahrenheit in your head  start with o4  then add 12 to get 16 28 and 40.  to convert these celsius numbers to  fahrenheit you basically reverse the  digits  o4 becomes 40 16 becomes 61 28 becomes  82  for the last one you reverse and add 100  so 40 becomes 104  now another trick since each scale is a  linear function of the other you can  easily estimate values in between by  averaging  let's say you wanted to convert 50  degrees fahrenheit  this is about halfway between 40 and 61  so the celsius value will be about  halfway between 4 and 16  this is 10.  this is a nice little trick but if you  need more precision you can always use  the exact formulas for conversion